this is overwhelming are there
instructions i'm about to review all of
these kickstarter health products and
one of them just happens to be the most
funded kickstarter fitness product of
all time
[Music]
santa brought a little gift bag fitness
hardware fair you ready for some fitness
okay
why does it sound like there's sand
intermission for the musical guest known
as the maraca mic
familiarize yourself with able moves
tips and tricks by watching the video on
their website okay i'm not going to do
that i'm just going to go ahead and get
right into it
cat cow first to warm up the low back
thanks for joining this class today
we're going to be doing a 30 minute
power
roller ride with your dog in frame
[Music]
i don't really know what i'm supposed to
do i feel like i should watch their
website
[Music]
that definitely breaks the sweat
okay so if you are gonna start this up
make sure you start really slow and you
know what you're able to handle before
you do it otherwise i think it's pretty
cool
hands eyes eyes closed okay oh oh okay
it's a bump bumbler smart vacuum gum
care it's a vacuum
this looks funny wow it's kind of funny
feeling
triggers my gag reflex a little bit
how about
i don't think i can do oh my god the
foam toothpaste just has non-english
writing on it and it expired in 2021 all
right we'll still use it
oh man i'm already gagging
[Music]
okay i i i had to fight that one oh and
it made my gums bleed cool someone
watched one too many sci-fi movies and
they're like all right we need to create
a device that does the same thing that
the manual toothbrush does but does it
worse
[Music]
this feels like a bag welcome to team
exerbelt fill up with water or sand to
the desired level press out air and fold
at least three times carefully close
buckle and attach handle okay gains
gains hinge you hear the water splashing
kickback action what do you think about
them apples huh i like it yeah
i think these are called russian twists
i like the sound
high five
oh
feels like a box it's a box i need to
see where this is from korea okay
wavewear scientific solution for better
performance okay i'm boxing now i need
better performance anti-bacterial
anti-odor multi-directional stretch i
feel like almost all fabric is
multi-directional stretch have you ever
stretched a t-shirt and been like oh
only stretches in one way permanent
adhesion
i would be concerned
okay these look like basic compression
gear let's flip this inside out there's
like little areas of silicone it like
prevents it from moving and keeps it in
place oh man this is sticky i already
feel it rubbing oh
i guess i'll put the pants on yeah
yeah
what do you think
it's very trim i think this whole
silicone sliding thing is a little
ridiculous i can't imagine that does
anything
together
it's a little weighty
okay we have well bricks weld bricks are
our modular system of massage bricks
designed to heal prevent injury or just
make you feel great an effective
alternative to rollers and balls almost
nipple-like protrusions here i really
should say utter like this almost looks
like the bottom of a cow the brick is
going inside my back not the nub oh
it hurts the nub doesn't protrude far
enough away from this
i need longer nubs you can get so much
more from a lacrosse ball or a tennis
ball if you don't want that much
pressure
[Music]
okay smaller one it's a high quality
jump rope training system okay we have a
rope that you have the handles which
look really cool actually this is a
beautiful design cut the cable at the
right distance following this picture
yeah i'm gonna measure it and it's
supposed to go up to your shoulder oh
there's like metal in here
[Music]
i don't think my scissors can cut
through now
dude there's no way my scissors it's
metal
oh here it cut you just needed some
really really sharp scissors
ah
clearly i'm not used to this system
oh and it hits it so bad
[Music]
why is it too long
i'm gonna show you how my jump rope
works so i can prove to you guys that i
can jump rope five dollar jump rope what
is the claim about this thing what does
it do it's called an earth 2.0 training
system besides making it more difficult
than the earth i'll show you that i'm
fully capable of jumping rope normally
with a seven dollar jump rope no problem
this is seven easy easy
why why is that other one cost so much
gently oh it's big but light
what am i looking at here
look at this it's a crossbow uyo fitness
nova personal gym there's like kind of
blades in here oh yeah top 10 exercises
chest slash back double flex
[Music]
bicep curl you feel those guns coming in
okay that feels kind of cool tricep
extensions not the most comfortable for
tricep push down that's okay lat row oh
yeah that's a lot row you feel that well
i'm worried this thing is going to snap
but i guess it's made really durably
this is the number one most funded
kickstarter fitness product of all time
i mean i can't verify that i think it's
actually a pretty cool product it's
really small these things seem to come
off really easy twist right pull to take
off yeah they come off real nice make
sure you have a little bit of a level of
fitness before jumping into this because
uncontrolled movements like this where
there's some flexibility and room for
error you can make some serious mistakes
so just be careful with that
why do i feel like this is a bag of
cigarettes and this is not a health
product why do you say a bag of sugar
yeah i got you kickstarter
wow i don't know what this is
[Music]
safe soft reusable and they come in
different colors you know my general
policy here you're not putting anything
into your ears you end up pushing the
earwax further back into your ear
tightening it up it hardens and then
when i go in to try and clear it out the
only way i can do it is by hurting you
feels light
you gave me socks arch tech arch support
system socks support and style there's a
little thickness on the inner foot but
you see this yellow spot this feels a
little more thick should we get the
foot people what they want okay
i'm about it i don't know what to say
about these it just feels like a kind of
an awkward sock unbiased walk test here
on one side i'm wearing a traditional
adidas compression sock on the other i'm
wearing this arch tech and my cracking
ankles this sock as i move it around i
could feel the air circulating around my
foot this one not so much like i don't
feel any circulation on my foot so that
could become a problem it could trap
heat it's probably gimmicky more than
anything else i would probably venture
and get an orthotic rather than rock a
sock to solve my problem
okay i guess i can't hold this one what
is it the most versatile and compact
body weight exercise system on the
market
this is a carrying case for it i've
always wanted a portable gym
[Music]
this is overwhelming are there
instructions
this has uh some questionable
metallic substance coming off of it
handles
bolts clips is this five minute
[Music]
crafts wow all right this is the full
pull-up dip assembly
[Music]
i mean it's a big piece of equipment i
guess like if you store this under your
bed
[Music]
that's kind of cool
i get it well what do you think overall
i think if you're committing this much
time to working out there's probably
easier ways to do it there's like
pull-up bars that you can put in your
doorway if you're really serious about
it it's not a bad product i actually
like it i'm trying to find a flaw in it
and to me just feels a little too
tedious that was a hard workout routine
bear really enjoyed it he's sniffing all
the products click here for my wish
product review video featuring the botez
chess sisters
bear
tell them to click it as always stay
happy and healthy